the german constitution of 1949 was more
concise than many user manuals
but in the 65 years since it was
approved it has undergone many revisions
as the german parliament gathered to
mark the anniversary those changes came
under criticism
especially from the guest of honor
writer navid karmani
the son of iranian immigrants
it seemed that germany had established a
permanent openness with its constitution
but now it's precisely that constitution
that shuts out those people who most
rely on that openness that politically
persecuted
the politically persecuted enjoy the
right to asylum
a wonderfully succinct sentence in 1993
it was transformed into a monstrous
edict of 275 convoluted words
to hide just one thing namely that
germany had practically abolished asylum
as a fundamental right
germans had to gradually adjust to
democracy after the end of the second
world war
but he praised the authors of the
constitution saying they established the
basis for a modern
and open-minded nation
they would today probably notice and
approve of the fact that a child of
immigrants is paying tribute to the
constitution
even though he belongs to a different
religion than the majority
speech was critical lively and a
testament to democracy on many counts
in the name of all the muslims who in
germany enjoy rights
shamefully denied to christians in many
islamic countries
in the name of my devout parents and an
immigrant family that now numbers 26
people
i would like to say and give a symbolic
bow
thank you germany
earned him a standing ovation
you